wir nehmen jetzt einfach gold so und
kaufen da bin ich auch echt mal gespannt
sind die ankommt etwas ab und jetzt
willkommen bei einem neuen video auf
meiner schnellen kanal
ich hoffe euch geht's gut das geht
anders gedacht und jetzt willkommen beim
ein video jahre hatte ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht sagen ungefähr vor
drei tagen kam ein video 100% zufällig
auf amazon bestellen braucht ihr nicht
gesagt habe wenn ich das noch mal machen
soll dass man doch noch oben da und
schreibt ein kommentar mit welchen
produkten halt wenn ihr das video noch
nicht gesehen habt dann schaut sich
einfach nach diesem video an ich habe
mir allerdings für heute gedacht wir
machen das ganze nicht auf sondern auch
ruhig kennt ihr das durch punkt kommt
also ich habe von der plattform schon
mal gehört allerdings konnte ich dann
mit wirklich niemals anfangen ich glaube
ich habe auf youtube öfter schon gesehen
so irgendwie milchprodukte vorstellung
was ist realität oder so es sind auch so
eine plattform da kannst du allen
möglichen scheiß bestellen
falls ihr das nicht kennt wobei ich
denke dass wahrscheinlich die meisten
von euch kennen werden sollte wir sind
jetzt hier gerade auch ruhig ja wie man
hier sieht
ich bin mir auch zum zweiten mal der
liste drauf und ich denke mir so ein
hopper wird für 8 euro
das kann auch nicht im wahrscheinlich
ist es dann in sport ist nur eine tasche
für hoppe wird ja das ist ja auch gemein
da kommen wir da hast du hier so ein
haus dort und im endeffekt ist es nur
eine tasche von superstar racing bananas
freestyles pfannen gift ja wie man schon
sehen kann es gibt alle möglichen scheiß
gut dann würde ich sagen will aber gar
nicht lange prinzip geht folgendermaßen
ihr habt mir ganz viele produkte wieder
in die kommentare stehen davon sucht
hier mal ein netter assistent bist du
eigentlich männlich oder weiblich sagt
okay wenn sie sucht die artikel namen
raus und dann muss ich dir hier eingeben
dann haben wir hier den zufallsgenerator
und derzeit halt irgendeine zahl an
und die erreicht auch jetzt die muss ich
dann nimmt das witzige heute ist dass
ich aus
dass ich die ganzen produkte die später
im warenkorb sind also ich würd sagen
machen sie zwölf produkte nicht selber
zahlen muss sondern weil marie so ein
toller vision ist es okay dann würde ich
sagen wir haben gar nicht lange für noch
ein paar gibt doch nach oben auf durch
8000 like so eine gute zahl und jetzt
kannst du den ersten artikeln vorlesen
fußballtrikot das gut im fußballtrikot
kann ich gebrauchen keine artikel
gefunden hatte vielleicht gebe ich das
mal auf englisch ein netz habe ich weiß
aber das ist kein fußball trikot ok dann
auch einfach so heute wir haben jetzt
hier die 41 24 ist voll hässlich okay
achso größe wählen in welcher farbe gibt
nur rot ok kaufen
das habe ich im warenkorb ein ersparnis
ist 149 europa alles klar
13 euro aber die haben mir geschrieben -
100 also eigentlich kostet ist 162 euro
okay wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt
da gibt es viel okay das erste
das ist teuer das richtig teuer zumal
die 450 ist schon teuer ist es ist von
324 runtergesetzt auf 113
aber wir haben ja auch echt richtig
coolen lego jet des so groß wie das kind
was oben drüber liegt gut meinen china
heißt lege und nicht legal sondern lebt
ich würde sagen wir machen weiter mit
den nächsten produkt und das ist gut
oder gut ist bestimmt 100 prozent
original das erste produkt hayta eine
gucci hose runter gesetzt von 208 euro
auf 49 kaufen die sache nicht und ich
bin dann mal gespannt was das für eine
qualität ist weil das kann ja eigentlich
mit der letzte chance sein oder so wäre
eine größe weihnachten eigentlich okay
guttenberg ist drin meine ersparnisse
des 199 euro wir kommen wir schon zur
nächsten sache und zwar bitte penis
kissen penis kissen events was heißt
kissen auf englisch schon aber das
zeugte 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
[Musik]
das brauche ich nicht okay wäre eine
größere eins oder zwei und wir werden
jetzt schon ein sehr komisches
fußball-trikot ein lego jet eine gucci
hose und ein penis
[Musik]
riesen einhorn riesen ein und gibt es
nichts was heißt einfach bringen die
unicorn weg unicorn wir haben ja auch
der 2 einen pulli mit einem lebenden
einfach aber das habe ich so etwas
generator 4 1 4 1 euro und was ist das
jetzt weder eine größe 1 ockel
wir nehmen dieses kostet zwei euro ok go
selbst schnäppchen ich hab gehört man
kann ja sogar produkte kaufen die kosten
gar nicht aber bis jetzt habe ich noch
keins von diesen produkten entdeckt
nein ich wollte nur kurz kommt ob das
wirklich stimmt
das kostet alles ein euro ja toll ja wir
kommen zum nächsten sache dünner aus der
dose das wird es noch niemals geben
döner aus der dose gibt es nichts was
gibt man nudeln gibt es auch nichts okay
wir sollen wir das sehen lassen
ok sehen das 123 48 und die zehen und
wir haben hier
wir haben ja ein barbecue grill brett
guck mal da kannst du das fleisch
pflegen so als wären wir schon einen
grill brett und noch so einen einfachen
was aber außer den pinguin nicht viel
hatte und jetzt dass wir für die produkt
das 12
da gibts nur ketten 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 und
das zwölfte ist ein schmetterling für
wunderschön wir machen weiter willkommen
zur nächsten satz von aixtron aixa.etr
geil bestimmt ich sag 10 euro rolex das
zweite produkt aber wir haben hier eine
wunderschöne originale rolex in goldmann
hatte das finde ich so krassen es gibt
leute die geben 15.000 euro 30.000 euro
für eine rolex aus und ich finde einfach
hier für 17 euro lag die auch sicherlich
original ist
wir nehmen es einfach gold so und kaufen
hey da bin ich auch echt mal gespannt
wenn die an komplette wir können ja mal
kurz in den warenkorb gehen was schätzen
denn wie viel geld die viel geld
ausgeben muss
[Musik]
235 euro was gibt es noch eine pizza
maschine das dritte produkt ist aber ein
pascal roller maschinen verdiene ein
spaghetti nudel maker es nicht ganz so
schlecht aus da kannst du deine eigenen
nudeln mitmachen
das kaufe ich willst du lieber in silber
oder in der favela eine farbe und wir
kommen zu den letzten produkten noch
drei stück einfach alex was hat bitte
eine uhr mit alex wie zu tun weiß wie
weh ja das ist mir umgeht touchscreen
smart touch mit kamera für 17 euro
als wenn das funktioniert für 17 euro
die kamera die ist doch der komplette
abschluss oder
ja ich auch in gold oder in silber und
schwarz oder in weiß halt im gold was
gibt es noch
er ist wie eine playstation übrigens er
aber immer eins für welches produkt 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 wir haben hier eine
plech zeit nein das kann nicht sein
2 playstation controller für fünf euro
wahrscheinlich ja aber das ist einfach
nur eine aufladestation dafür aber fünf
euro ist das gar nicht mal schlecht aber
es wenn diese aufladestation sonst 81
euro kostet niemals dürfen sich wahre
held tage und wir kommen noch zum grünen
abschluss und haben noch ein produkt 834
50 sie macht war ohne witz ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen dieses pulli dingen hat
was dies ist politisch
wir nehmen das einfach mal ein bisschen
aufpassen erhält das nicht gut
also ich bin gespannt so und kaufen so
leute jetzt haben wir hier
wahrscheinlich zwölf produkte im
warenkorb
wir haben hier jetzt einmal das football
gold keeper shirt ach so dass ein
torwart trikot
na gut das macht dann sind dann haben
wir hier den lego jet 113 runtergesetzt
von 324 dann haben wir die kurse dann
haben wir das penis kissen das ist für
22 beruht dann das pinguin einholen dann
haben wir die grillplatte dann
blue schmetterling rolex und pizza
maschine eine touch mit kamera
wahrscheinlich da bin ich echt gespannt
die playstation und dieses komische
shirt und wir sind als insgesamt 287
euro für kippen wir kürzlich eine
bankkarte bitte leute also das wird
jetzt bestellt wenn das ganze zeug da
ist dann werde ich ein video dazu machen
und euch das zeigen also ich hoffe dass
wieder durchgefallen
seid gespannt wenn die produkte ankommen
ich bin auch sehr selber gespannt selber
sehr gespannt wollte ich sagen bei 8006
gibt es neue folge davon 100 prozent
zufällig bestellen und ja wir sind uns
eventuell schon brauchen wieder haut
rein mit sibirischen durchsuchen war
ganz okay sie aus mehreren oder